[موسيقى]
انه لبنان الارض التي تابى ان تريح اهلها
ويابى اهلها الا ان يستريحوا فيها فيقبل
ابنائها على الانتحار تاركين ما فوقها من
هموم وازمات ليستقروا تحت ترابها لعله
يكون اكثر هدوءا وطمانينه من المستقبل
المجهول
[موسيقى]
الازمه الاقتصاديه الخانقه التي تعاني
منها البلاد منذ عده اعوام دفعت الكثيرين
الى اللجوء الى الخيار الصعب فمع صعوبه
الحياه اصبح الموت اكثر الطرق سلوكا
لتتصدر حالات الانتحار مشهد الحياه
اليوميه بين اللبنانيين وليحمل الاسبوعان
الماضيان نحو ست حالات انتحار لفئه عمريه
مختلفه
[موسيقى]
وكما يشير الخبراء النفسيون فان الضغوط
التي تقع على كاهل الانسان اللبناني ادت
الى تفاقم اوضاع النفسيه وصحيه معقده من
قلق واكتئاب ليكون التكيف معها صعبا خصوصا
مع ضعف الدعم الاجتماعي الامر الذي يؤدي
في النهايه للعجز والياس الذي يوصل الى
اتخاذ سلوكيات انتحاريه
[موسيقى]
صعبه في هذه البقعه من الارض لا يمكن
انكار هذه الحقيقه لكن الاصعب هو اتخاذ
مثل هذا القرار الذي لا شك يزيد الالم
والقهر في نفوس من فقدوا احبتهم نتيجه
لحظات من التفكير السلبي التي ربما يمكن
تجاوزها بالقليل من الامل والكثير من الحب
لصباح العربيه رينادويه